christophe tripodi président de
l'association des commerçants du
quartier méditerranée et président de
l'association force économique unis
bonjour christophe tripodi merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
nice en confinement depuis hier soir
comment vivez-vous cette mesure déjà en
tant qu' en tant que commerçant et en du
moins nous n'ouvrirons du moins c'est de
me dire de manière difficile parce que
pan déjà depuis des mois nous sommes
nous subissons le manque de touristes à
nice et à nouveau bon on est cons et
qu'on finisse et le dire qu'on va perdre
encore du chiffre d'affaires de plus
pour ça j'ai aussi beaucoup sur le sur
le mental des gens donc ça c'est ainsi
une double sanction pour seulement
économique mais aussi morale qu'elles
auraient pu être les autres solutions
qu'est ce que vous en tant que
commerçant vous auriez a pu imaginer
nous nous en tant que commerçant c'est
sûr que bon on n'a pas peut-être pas
encore les du mal à le recul par rapport
à nos aliments au gouvernement je pense
qu'ils essaient de faire le maximum avec
les moyens les moyens qu'ils ont mais
nous nous pensons que surtout que le bon
c'est un virus équin partie ce moment là
nous pouvons pas l'arrêter et au lieu
d'essayer de nous confiner je pense
qu'il faudrait trouver des solutions
pour vivre avec
aujourd'hui bon c'est le co vie de
demain ce sera sûrement autre chose donc
il faut plutôt trouver des solutions
pour justement faire attention et est
arrivé à travailler tout en faisant en
prenant des mesures sanitaires
est-ce qu'on revient dans les pays
voisins pendant ce temps on dort à
monaco par exemple restaurant bon sens
couverts le midi
donc il ya quand même eu deux vies parce
qu'il ya pas non plus que le que le
confinement aujourd'hui on va être des
gens qui mentalement sont vraiment
touché
d'ailleurs on voit bien pour des gens
qui se suicident et tout ça donc c'est
ça qui est très difficile en tant qu' en
tant que commerçant est ce que vous vous
sentez parfois la cible prioritaire
justement de ces mesures de restriction
oui nous surtout bon moi je suis aussi
grossiste en alimentation donc on a été
fortement sanctionné par le par cette
crise
maintenant bon c'est vrai que le
gouvernement a été nommément d'argent
pour justement essayer de de nous aider
en tant qu'entreprise même si bon des
fois la décision elle semble tardif mais
en tout cas on sait que bon ils sont
quand même là le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui bon
soutien à l'économie mais le jour où le
gouvernement ne va plus à soutenir
qu'est ce qui va se passer je pense
qu'il y aura beaucoup beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont qui vont fermer
et ans qui vont être liquidée il y
aurait un taux de chômage important
donc si aujourd'hui on apprend pas du
moins on voit bien que le les mesures de
confinement non non je n'ai jamais rien
abouti
c'est sûr ça fait baisser peut-être le
niveau des malades dans les hôpitaux
mais le problème il est que bon il ya
toujours le virus qui circule comme en
plus important je pense à aujourd'hui
c'est souvent de trouver des mesures qui
puissent nous permettre de vivre avec
comment les commerçants niçois justement
comptent s'organiser pour faire face aux
pertes à venir là sur les sur les deux
prochains week-ends aujourd'hui je pense
que des fois je pense qu'il on perd un
peu le moins de on appuie languit du
moins là on se on y résigner
voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
résigné alors c'est sûr qu'on parle
aujourd'hui du click and collect etc
mais ce sont des le problème c'est que
ceux des modèles économiques qu'on peut
pas mettre en place et un jour au
lendemain
ce n'est pas possible donc il ya une
résignation et puis il ya de lassitude
et je pense que bon maintenant les c'est
vrai que les peugeot vont arriver donc à
prat histoire on va le lui on pense que
le virus doit baisser que voilà on va
retrouver j'ai un peu une vie une vie
normale mais c'est vrai que mentalement
c'est très très difficile
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
situations très difficiles voire même de
suicides chez certains commerçants
quelle est la situation actuellement des
commerçants à nice est ce que certains
ont déjà mis la clé sous la porte est ce
que ça va arriver dans les jours à venir
qu'est ce qu'on vous raconte vraiment
sur le terrain
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le l'économie je
me dis encore une fois il est soutenu
parce que bon il ya eu les pge il ya les
aides de l'état dont il soutenu le
problème il est que quand il n'y aura
plus ça il va y avoir de casse et c'est
ça le gros souci qu'on va y avoir dans
plus bon nous on est à nice en raison de
cette touristique
on n'a pas les rues si on n'a pas les
chinois on n'a pas les américains on n'a
pas les anglais donc aujourd'hui on est
en plus en plus on ne sait même pas
quand est-ce qu'ils vont revenir
donc c'est très très difficile pour nous
en plus à chaque fois que mon cas les
congés les gens viennent chez nous donc
obligatoire une romaine le virus aussi
parce qu'il a ce problème là aussi donc
quand christian estrosi par exemple dit
que bonds qui veut limiter les locations
et ses râles peut-être non plus parce
que justement ça évite peut-être aux
gens de venir chez nous et de nous et de
nous de nous amener le tout le virus
merci bonjour
christophe tripoli excusez moi je vous
ai coupé à lady terminé jeudi et voilà
juste moi seule chose je pense
qu'aujourd'hui voilà il faut vraiment
apprendre à vivre avec faire attention
prendre des mesures nécessaires et puis
et continuer à vivre et à beaurains et à
avoir une vie parce que sinon il y en a
qui meurent du module du coc vite mais
il y en a qui vont mourir de 2,2
mentalement parce qu'ils sont touchés
c'est très difficile voilà merci
beaucoup christophe tripoli d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association des commerçants du
quartier méditerranée et président de
l'association force économique uni merci
beaucoup